today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet join
them at expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
i guess i really got in my own world i
didn't think his name would be that big
of a meme
so like when it became like a giant meme
i was like oh
like i already [ __ ] my kid i think it
behooves most any adult
who wants to understand what's going on
with the younger generation to try and
spend a few hours on tick tock
there isn't like a tech safety community
that's super large like it's quite small
you're supposed to be a tortured artist
or whatever but it's like it's actually
kind of um
edgy to be wholesome at this point
artists have the same impact on a
community's economic development as
entrepreneurs the situation in music
worries me like i know artists that are
pretty successful that are like
broke i'm like super into brutalist
architecture at the moment and i
thought like brutalist baby like you
know like just like
a square cement crib would be kind of
[Music]
cool
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks it is
election day it's election day 11 or
whatever it is now i'm kidding
election day 11 election week two
yes that's sad so i
i'm getting a lot of questions zach
about hey like are these trump legal
actions going to actually
uh succeed should we be concerned
i understand why people would be
concerned because you you'd put nothing
past
this administration but it's a wrap you
know
like that's what i wanted to do i wanted
to like let's i want to debunk
i want to get to like facts of the
recount
nonsense voter fraud nonsense going on
because it's mostly nonsense but
if you're a game i'd love your thoughts
on what's real and what's truth right
now because the source of truth
to me is a moving target right now well
the the truth is that
joe has a margin of victory
in pennsylvania georgia
arizona nevada um that that's high
enough
uh that it's going to make a recount
like impossible to succeed wisconsin
uh where i think it was scott walker the
republican governor of wisconsin who
said
look we can make a mistake of 100
200 300 maybe 400 votes
we're not going to make a mistake of 20
000 votes
like you know it's like we know how to
count um and this is a republican
governor uh and you know so who's been
pro-trump in some ways you know
or yeah if you will like a lot of these
states have republican secretaries of
state
georgia republican secretary of state
pennsylvania republican secretary of
state like they're the folks
so uh so what's happening is you have
very
hyper partisan impulses being like it's
a fraud you screwed up
uh and then when the show would be like
okay like what evidence are you claiming
they'll like just snatch some
strange like you know account or video
that um most often gets explained away
um or
accounts for you know like maybe like
one to ten votes where you could be like
okay maybe like that that but like
there's no uh claim of like and then
they dumped
25 000 fake votes in there but it was
like you know like
there's nothing uh that would influence
the outcome of the election so here's
what's really going on
um the republicans know they've lost but
they need donald trump's voters through
january 5th the georgia special
elections which we'll talk about and uh
you and i are heading to georgia
um yes sir shortly so that's that's
exciting not
to vote ourselves to help other people
vote i'm gonna say that yeah yeah just
to draw attention and raise money and
rally but
uh you know that's not going to yeah no
it really is it's like
like that there's like uh it is not
andrew yang's fault
or my fault that george's laws on voting
residency are ridiculous apparently you
can move there and
just register to vote that's ridiculous
not our fault not our plan keep going
yeah no
exactly take it up with the georgia
state legislature so
uh so the republicans have
reasoned that they need trump's voters
january 5th
and so they're going to play along with
the entire trump
uh fraud game um because they
just want to maintain energy levels
because they think if trump's just out
of the picture and he concedes then all
of his supporters will stay home january
5th
and the democrats have a better chance
of winning these special elections
um but i think you said zach that what's
telling is that
trump and pence are essentially on
vacation now you know they're like
chilling like
everyone in their administration uh is
looking around being like
uh okay i guess i need a new job and
then
um their leadership is like you have to
pretend that everything is still normal
that will be here
and if you don't then we'll fire you
before even like
like uh um you can leave so so that that
so that's the situation it's cynical
it's political
like a lot of things in american life um
and
uh it's trying to maintain
hold of the senate january 5th
so here's my thought on this stuff is
would that make sense to me um
and then for those of you like because i
think disinformation becomes a problem
when rational republicans
who are not the die-hard base but like
rational moderate republicans
or moderate libs on the on the other
side start to
parrot what the far right or far left is
saying
and i think that's what's happening here
it's really frustrating because i have
you know irrational either rational
pundits or rational friends of mine
they're like well there seemed to be
some shenanigans going on
which is frustrating because here here's
what's up that
i like recounts so if like the
republicans want to just say hey we want
to recount the votes
fine totally fine we should do that in
democracy so i'm 100 on board we did it
we've done it before we'll do it again
but here's the
the counts are biden's ahead by 20 000
votes in wisconsin 145 000 in michigan
13 000 arizona 14 000 in georgia
almost 50 000 in pennsylvania so some of
these are close
but not a couple signatures and note
even if there was a freakish thing where
one of them gets overturned joe still
wins like you you need to overturn
several of them yes so bo and jose
essentially needs three
maybe two depending on how you which
ones you pick here i think pennsylvania
and georgia i believe it's over right by
the math
so um the other thing is there has been
this is the other fact of the case
because republican lawyers and judges
generally speaking 99.9 of them believe
in the rule of law
and they're looking at this not a single
judge a j
all judges have thrown out the cases
presented to them
that have been at the scale that could
flip the election
right because there's no evidence of it
being accepted right it's clearly just
accepted over the small ones
yeah so that's there's no real evidence
at all
of voter fraud and that is frustrating
this election is big guys it happened
joe biden got more votes both nationwide
and the states he needed
he's the president-elect donald trump's
on the way out
and the republicans would be
acknowledging this to a much higher
degree if not for the special elections
in georgia in my opinion
so uh no you're probably right so so
just keep in mind that
like they they see the there's an
incentive balance of power in the senate
as potentially at stake and then that's
made them much more willing to
play along right and that makes their
life hell
comparatively speaking right like they
have a lot of incentive
to want power in their power in the
senate because then congress actually
can do stuff
um well democrats need you know it's
like yeah republicans
both of them right the leadership yeah i
mean they both need it
yeah um let me ask you this i think this
is a fun trevor noah had this point
which i don't
always love trevor noah but sometimes
he's funny he said uh so on one hand
this um claims of voter fraud
are hurting democracy in our trust in
elections and something you talk about a
lot
on the other hand on a more fun hand
there is a chance we see donald trump
dragged out of the white house which i
think would be
funny from a comedy standpoint
in an entertainment standpoint which i
think is trump's lame like i think he's
entertainer to me
thoughts on that which you'd rather see
i imagine i know where you land um
but have you thought he's not gonna let
us get dragged out he's gonna walk out
of there
like the the day before and do a photo
op and like hop in a helicopter a plane
give us the bird and flip us the burden
and have a headache yeah yeah
you're probably right and then millions
of americans will continue to support
him and then you know we'll see what his
future holds
um yeah the the problem really is like
the muddiness between now and then
because still
he's the president between now and then
so he's firing people he's making
decisions
uh fired his secretary he's fired
secretary defense right who said yeah
uh then i quote uh if it's a yes man god
help us all
yeah the uh
the transition's getting gummed up
because ordinarily um
the biden team would have some resources
to work with and be talking to current
officials and a bunch of other things
uh and that that has not happened so
that's
uh that that's negative substantively
for
an effective trade-off of or hand-off of
power
um and that sucks you know that i mean
this there's no bones about it like that
this
like we just hung on through this and
like it's still happening
where you have like you said i guess
formerly reasonable republicans being
like oh like about let's play the sound
like
it's bad for the country that the
incoming team cannot talk to the current
team
uh it's bad for the country that
millions of americans are being called
to like question
uh the objective fact of who got more
votes
like this stuff's really destructive and
it's speeding up
you know it's like the norms just held
together
uh for this one uh you know next time if
the next person
says this stuff is rigged like you know
you you might see
uh unrest and um
like worse judging or you know whatever
the heck uh
you know it is so like this is not going
well
uh for american democracy uh you know
like i'm thrilled that joe and kamala
won but
uh and i i wish that you know
republicans didn't have these political
incentives to cast this like alternate
version of reality
uh where clearly and like all these
republicans are being like oh they're
like issues shenanigans they
do a recount if trump had won they would
be crowing immediately being like
you know it's in the bag stop it like we
don't need to count more like the
rest of it i mean you saw it so clearly
where like the chant was different
depending upon what state and what the
needs were it was like stop the count or
count every vote or whatever it was you
know
you know they'll like flip on the dawn
it's a tough argument because there's so
many states yeah
so they're i mean the the the core of it
is just that they want their team to win
and um and that's
in some ways understandable because we
all want our teams to win um
but you know at this level like that
there has to
be some degree of um country over
party you know it's like this stuff is
really bad for the
country it's bad for the country that an
incoming government like can't talk to
the current government it's bad for the
country that
like you have this floundering executive
branch for
you know two solid months like you know
that like that they're just real real
negatives to this
um and like i i don't i think this hand
holding
of republicans who want to play along is
uh is is corrosive you know like i wish
they
didn't feel but you know i guess it's
like the epitaph to the trump era it's
like well we kind of wish republicans
had
separated from him this entire time and
been like yo this guy's
you know not the guy and they never did
and so they're still playing it out
they're still writing his
trump coattails to what they hope is
political victory in georgia
uh country be damned you know it it um
like uh it's a sad day or a sad week or
two weeks or three weeks or whatever it
is you know you've talked a lot
i'm gonna find this quote this quote and
tweet it before this podcast where you
found
you said we're entering an era i think
you said this at cnn town hall
your first one where you said we're
entering era of um
the lack of institutional trust where we
don't trust our schools we don't trust
our
our military we don't trust our
education system and
um we don't trust government and now
it's looking at we don't trust our
elections
we don't trust the media straw we don't
just yeah there's a whole bunch in this
list yeah
yeah actually zack military is the most
trusted of those institutions you just
named
like uh so of course i butchered your
quote that's actually a good example
no no it's i mean like the military's
like the last bastion that gets like
majority trust uh we don't trust
hospitals we don't trust doctors
you know it's like the the the trust is
low um
the trust is declining further still
this election unfortunately
has not been good for trust
you've talked about this before but um
we never really debated it so
there's there's liberal chatter um
and not like far left stuff like
politico wrote about this where um
there's rumors that trump will have um
some civil suits and possibly face jail
time
from um certain courts when he leaves
the white house
um and you've been on record saying you
hate that because that turned us into
venezuela and i agree with that no i i'm
saying i hate going i hate criminal
prosecution
um the civil suits have added you know
he owes you money go for it
[Laughter]
um like i do think it's bad practice for
a new government to like throw the
previous president
in jail uh you know because that's a
pattern that
goes on in uh developing countries where
like the new president's always trying
to like chase down the
former president who's still a potential
threat
uh yeah and i know there there are going
to be many people who disagree with
this because they want to see trump in
jail really really badly
uh like i i think it would be um i would
think it would do more harm than good
to try to imprison trump and and i also
think that
again just like the odds of seeing him
dragging out the white house the odds of
him actually going to jail would be so
low you know he would just
decamp to another country where he would
uh um
live it up nope
but i do think like if he owes money
like particularly the new york
um
[Music]
you know here at yang speaks we are all
about protecting
our data i am so thrilled that prop 24
passed in california california's are
enjoying
higher data protection rights they're
going to create a new data protection
agency just for california
and if that sounds cool to you and
you're not in california then go to your
state legislators and say hey
how come californians have better data
protections than we do here in wisconsin
in michigan in ohio wherever let's have
the sweep the country
in the meantime if you want to protect
your personal data every time you use
the internet
we recommend expressvpn vpn stands for
virtual private network it's like you
beam into the internet
from someplace else no one can track
what you're doing they can't sell and
resell your data
it's like you're a ghost a spy someone
really cool from the future
who no one knows what the heck they did
if that sounds good to you expressvpn
is your product visit expressvpn.com
yang that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn dot-com slash gang for three months
free with a one-year package
this is the number one rated vpn by
wired cnet in the verge
visit expressvpn.com to learn more
[Applause]
so so let's get to let's get to georgia
why is everybody
going to georgia over the next two
months
you had not one but two senate races
in georgia which is highly unusual and
neither of the quote-unquote
winners or front-runners got 50 percent
so in georgia there's a rule where if
you don't get 50
you go to a runoff so race number one is
john ossoff
against uh david perdue and
uh that was close as a two-point race or
so um
john ossoff's very young very logical
uh really impressive candidate to have
um
uh accomplished so much uh i talked to
him the other day and he was joking
about how
when he ran for congress it ended up
being like the most important
congressional race of
um the year because it was the first one
post-trump uh and then now his senate
race is becoming the most important so
he's like joking he's like lightning
striking twice
uh and then the other race um
is reverend rafael warnock against kelly
lefler
and both purdue and lefleur were accused
of
insider trading on coronavirus
information when they first found out
how bad the chronovirus was going to be
they
did what any american would do and
adjust their stock portfolio
they were just like oh this is going to
be bad for cruise lines
you know it's like that's leadership
that's leadership uh
that's so illegal by the way it's so
having worked on wall street that is
like textbook insider trading there's
not like that's not even a gray area
yeah
the entire um legislative access to
tradable information i mean come on like
we haven't figured this one out
like if you're gonna show up in congress
just like put your money in a trust
they like throw it in a bunch of things
you can't touch it and then you come out
of public service you get it back
instead we're creating all of these gray
areas where legislators are freaking
profiting
it is not a good look that folks enter
congress
non-millionaires and leave millionaires
on the regular you know like
like that that's and it happens all the
time
all the time and it makes sense because
there's
it's not illegal to do this you go in
and sit there in a meeting like wow
it looks like this massive xyz problem
is causing oil prices to skyrocket in
the middle east like oh better like
get out of my oil companies and you go
in there and you make your trade and
then let it go and then yeah you don't
lose all that money and like there's a
moral like taking care of your family
thing but that's highly illegal it's not
cool
um well yeah i mean congress hasn't
hasn't
like slammed the door on this stuff to
the degree that it could
right it needs to for sure i mean it'd
be illegal in
some of these other contexts you're
talking about um so yeah like all the
demands but there needs to be rules and
like inside trading's hard
to track in general but this one's easy
this one's easy
well zach i'll tell you the enrichment
of congressional
members is not strictly that they just
have better intel they're like you know
like adjusting their
um e-trade portfolio or something like
that like
most of most of it is that you get in
there and then all of a sudden like
people just want to include you in
everything including
things that um that can make you some
money and
they're technically legitimate uh but
just people will be like hey
you know like we've got some real estate
deal like you wanna
come like uh partake and like there's
not no rule against it you're like you
know a citizen you can
invest and so people just be like trying
to carve out awesome opportunities for
you
then before you know it like you know
you're trouncing the market many many
times over
if you're a member too you're like
hanging out with rich people all the
time
and then the rich people kind of put
their hand on your shoulder and they're
like
they're there like we like you you
should be rich like us
and then and then the members like are
like yes i should
and then before you know it they are
anyway this is actually a long
digression from the fact that that's
very real man
and i'll say this quickly because i saw
this like if you have people always like
the rich get richer
like poor poor like when you have money
the investment opportunities get a lot
better and a lot less risky
in the sense that in 2000 i'll never
forget this we sold an apollo european
credit fund
awesome idea and basically in the 2009
financial crisis all like the smaller
banks mid-level banks in europe went
under
so private citizens if you're like the
cisco which is like the food delivery
service
super blue chip company you couldn't get
a loan in europe
so private citizens just pulled a bunch
of money together and we're loaning like
blue chip companies
at like 11 interest 15 interest it was
the closest thing to surefire bet
ever and all you had to do was have
enough money to lock it up so
it's stuff like that that they're
getting access to where
you and i like you you're poor you don't
you're not in the game you have to
invest in just
an apple stock or whatever s p 500 and
like go with those waves these guys get
sure things that the lead access that
kind of stuff so
long way to getting there but that's
just one that i remember very yeah i
mean
wow yeah you lived it brainerd if i had
money you know yeah then they'll call
you up and be like hey
i got a thing for you so tell me your
left foot yeah
and then you're like sure you feel smart
and it's corruptive over time
anyway kelly lefler uh is the richest
member of the senate which is saying
something because there are a lot of
freaking rich senators
but kelly left her lovely is worth 520
million she's already put 23 million
into a race
uh reverend raphael warnock uh you know
is a
black reverend uh very inspiring like
he's getting a lot of support um i and
this i'll just
say just because i think it's fun is
that kelly leflar also owns a wnba team
uh that like in all the players wanted
her to sell it because
she she was against the black lives
matter messaging look at the court like
yeah
it's like you probably should do
everyone a favor and sell that team if
like your players don't want to play for
you that way so uh so that's
that that's the other race these are
fascinating races
and uh we have to be realistic that for
democrats
it will be an uphill climb and you think
well why because didn't joe just win
this state like isn't georgia at purple
the problem is that uh republicans in
georgia have a much
tighter read on voting and the need to
vote
than democrats who many of them are new
to the process
and this was true a number of years ago
even there was a special election that
was very close to get to a special
election
it was maybe a three-point gap and then
the republican won it by double digits
maybe 12 points so that was a number of
years ago
so it's probably not going to be that
gruesome this time
but you have to expect that
democrats will come out at lower levels
and the trump not being on the ballot
thing cuts both ways is that they're
like you know
republicans are concerned that their
voters will stay home you know who'll
stay home a lot of anti-trump democratic
voters in georgia
uh so it's a it's an uphill climb uh
but we have to to make this happen
because the
alternative is mitch mcconnell saying no
to everything
for four years while the country sinks
into the mud
uh that's why i'm heading there and
you're heading there is that uh we have
such massive problems in this country
and we know washington will take any
excuse not to work
you know if the party can just look and
blame the other side me like well
nothing happened no stimulus bill
uh it's their fault vote them out of
office and then go eat a steak
um while while the you know the country
is
burning they'll do that you know i mean
that like that
like i mean we're seeing it we're
feeling it um
yeah for seven months so if you want uh
to
get things done out of washington that
might help people
a unified government would be enormously
superior to mitch mcconnell saying no no
no and mitch mcconnell all of a sudden
you know he's going to be like oh
the deficit like when like no one cared
when trump was like let's do a like
trillion dollar tax got to be like yeah
let's you know all the republicans have
voted because
of the fiscal situation the united
states to decrease the deficit
it went up exponentially essentially
donald trump had the biggest increase of
deficit in a long time
i'm going to see if i pull those numbers
up but go ahead so it's both it's a
[ __ ] argument
like and if there's any time you're
gonna deficit spend
it's when you have a pandemic and a
pandemic induced recession
and a jobs recession and like you know
like people
are getting kicked out of homes and
in food bank lines like if there is any
time you're going to deficit spend it
would be now
and one of the things that frustrates
the heck out of me is the confusion
around where the money is going karzak
2.2 trillion dollars
uh if you do the math 1200 for let's
call it 100 million americans
uh is something like six percent of
2.2 trillion dollars so it's like oh all
the money went to
people no you know like a like a tiny
sliver
went like you could give everyone twelve
hundred dollars
a month for a year with like that two
trillion dollars if you so chose
which by the way would have been vastly
superior
to what they did because let's say you
have an airline
i feel i feel very deeply and
desperately for all the families
you know the furloughed employees and
the rest of it but let's say
that all those employees were getting
like thousand dollars a month two
thousand dollars a month
and then the airline itself was getting
recapped like then how would you feel
we only care about the airline because
we care about the workers
we care about like the pilots the
airline attendants like
the rest of it's like i don't want those
people to suffer yeah no like i don't i
don't want those people to to suffer
you know the other thing is like we have
a sophisticated enough corporate
um infrastructure where like a banked or
bailout let's keep on flying anyway you
know
like they go to the creditors and be
like well i can't make any money if
we're not doing flights and i'm like
yeah yeah you go do that like
it's not like bankrupt firms just stop
operating
you know like the the the creditors can
just keep on you know like doing the
thing so
so there are many many better ways to go
so even if you are concerned about the
deficit
you should be clamoring for cash relief
because it is the most effective bang
for your buck
it would actually go right back in the
economy it would rejuvenate small
businesses keep some of these
restaurants open and all the rest of it
um and so having mitch mcconnell talk
about the deficit is something i will
desperately i will fight tooth and nail
to shut him up just be like look just
you know like just step aside
you've done enough wrecking of the
country for uh for a while
uh you know like let's try and rebuild
it
yang versus mitch i'm excited for this
for those just to make sure i get the
numbers right
um this is according to a site called
the balance which is like a
pretty i've read this before but a
pretty good uh
us debt uh blog website um but we've
increased the debt by
donald trump under donald trump's been
36 percent or so
almost 36 in the past four years now you
can give a chunk of that
kind of not all that is covered right
now a lot of that is the tax
cuts and there's this logic on the right
that say hey if we cut taxes people will
make more money
without the taxes and then they'll still
make it back and the reality is really
rich people don't
pay taxes so this is a ridiculous model
um
so that's our world right now and then
to be clear on this
if the democrats win these two senate
races we have a 50 50 tie in the senate
which means the tiebreaker goes to the
sitting vice president which means
which is going to be kamala harris so so
5150 advantage so would that not be
glorious that's what's on the line in
georgia that's why we're heading there
uh we've just kicked off
winboatseats.org
which donates to 16 community
organizations that activate
voters in georgia and in different
places in different
communities so we've identified this as
the most effective
use of resources uh it's a two month
sprint
and so you need people that can actually
talk to people
and um and these orgs do just that
they're actually very close to the
ground
um so uh you know we're gonna go there
too knock on doors like uh do some
things i'm gonna
try and activate some people while i'm
there it's been fun where a lot of
people have reached out to me being like
yeah you're gonna be in georgia like you
know like
i tweeted you this is hilarious um yeah
martin luther king the third
um like uh said yeah let's get lunch i
mean like you know that
it's it's like oh there's like a
beautiful yeah there's a beautiful
welcome wagon
um um in georgia which is a great place
dominique
like freaking love dominique oh yeah
dominique we'll see him in atlanta
dominique wilkins
um so a couple things um
i'll say this again i keep saying it but
i do think it's important because a lot
of the right
is is
like screaming this narrative if you
will where georgia has some weird
residency laws
and we said this before if you move
there you can pretty much vote pretty
immediately um which is
uh not great when um
you know protect potentially for
election fraud but the think of how that
would actually work where people
actually move
get a place and then move out for an
election it's not going to happen at
scale
but that's not the point we are going
there to help the campaigns
to help the democratic party to get out
the vote and register
new people to vote um so that's what
we're doing
more to come i mean guys we've now
turned these campaigns which are
probably what
30 i don't know the numbers of time we
have 30 to 50 million
operations each now it's going to be
combined hundreds of million dollar
operation
where the whole nation is now focused on
the state whether they like it or not so
a lot
is up in the air um we're figuring out
what we're going to do all we know now
that we're moving there and we found
some great orgs to work with instead of
tbd
um it's also covid which we'll talk
about a little bit on this podcast so
the in-person campaigning
not as fun as it was back in iowa in
january um
but let me ask you this andrea i think
it's really important um
because a lot of people see you i like
to call your lane the rational
progressive right where you're not
far left but you have really big ideas
um and you're not afraid to talk
um to criticize both parties you clearly
are democrat
you lean left on a whole bunch of things
almost everything but you also
are very rational and thoughtful um not
left or right forward is kind of what
you know
that's been our slogan
70 million americans voted for donald
trump there is a
to me it's also a healthy sign that um
we're not all like the country's very
divided so what are you
you're right now very supportive of
giving joe and kamala
full reign of the house and senate why
we're going to georgia you might explain
like why
a little more you touched on a little
bit but why are you even though there
were so many trump supporters
here that we saw it wasn't a mandate why
you're so passionate about the
the full control for joe
i i understand that there are some
people that are like ooh you know both
parties
um checks and balances compromise yeah
be nice to have the boundaries
you don't want to give everything yeah
like i understand that perspective
um i think we're in a very specific
situation right now
where we have a pandemic that is getting
worse not better
we have a three to four trillion dollar
hole in our economy
uh something like 40 million plus
americans have filed for unemployment
over the last period of time
and so the government needs to be taking
fairly dramatic measures
in order to stop the bleeding
uh and fill that hole and provide a path
for
tens of millions of americans
now if you look up at washington's
recent history
uh it's not great in terms of taking the
actions i'm describing
um but the track record plummets
when you have mitch mcconnell um playing
goalie or obstructionist
so if we lived in a world where the
republicans and democrats have been
working together harmoniously and like
hammering out legislation
and and then uh you were in this crisis
and you had confidence that they would
come together uh then maybe
you know it's like okay like that that
like that that might make sense but
that's not the world we live in like we
live in a world where
uh we haven't gotten another relief act
in seven months and counting and it's
probably going to be you know
unfortunately like significantly longer
because they're not going to pass the
law in the lame duck session
and in this circumstance you need
an invigorated government actually doing
things
i know it's painful for some people to
hear but that's where we are
half of independent restaurants are
going to close without some kind of
relief
like think about what that means for
communities around the country for
those jobs those people those families
that freaking spent a lifetime building
that restaurant put their heart and soul
into it and and now
are going to be forced to shut it
forever i mean like that's what we're
facing
unless our government actually uh
like passes the relief act for
restaurants small businesses
puts money into people's hands like the
the deprivation and desperation are
rising
uh and this is not the time to be like
uh like the
the bipartisanship you're talking about
is an abstraction like
uh like the reality has been sorely
disappointing
for years and years uh and so
if we're gonna get some kind of real
action out of congress we have a much
better chance at it
uh if mitch mcconnell uh is not
the final say i
think that was extremely well put i
think
the other to me what i look at is you
start to give joe options because joe
can go to mitch say hey i'm willing to
negotiate with you so you can get your
moderate republicans on board with a
bill that all americans get behind but
if not i'm gonna force something through
like that to me is what um a reasonable
president can do and i think joe will be
so that is why we're going to georgia
that's why this matters
um once we have details and you can or
you um
get off your butt and get down there but
if not also like we can phone bank you
can text bank you can fundraise
there's a whole bunch of virtual things
you can do as well so this is where the
focus is
with that we have a um really special
guest man this is like we've been
excited about this for
yeah like uh i'm such a huge grimes fan
on a personal level and a creative
level it's just a powerhouse we met on
the trail
um stayed in touch uh and
she became a mom and you know i dare say
you know like uh
um that um she's been
fairly low profile sense so like this
was like a special treat
uh on several levels but i just like i
just love
uh talking to her and she has so much to
offer
a lot of insight i think the world right
now
needs more art and uplift and that
stuff's underestimated
really like you know you talk about
politicians
um trying to be a source of that but i
think artists are a more consistent
source of that
in the vast majority of people's lives
you know what i mean it's like
if you want to feel good like what do
you do you probably turn on your
favorite
artist you turn on your favorite music
like you probably don't turn on like old
obama speeches or something um
you know maybe you do some people don't
turn down
yeah so so just learn a ton but more
importantly just
like um felt a real sense of joy
getting to catch up with grimes i hope
other people enjoy this conversation too
so thank you grimes hope everyone enjoys
it
uh is a treat for me yeah
and look she doesn't do a lot of these
it's a rare moment and
um i learned a lot and i think um you
guys
enjoyed so tune in grimes joins yang
speaks
[Music]
[Applause]
here at yank speaks we are all about
doing things better
doing things more efficiently doing
things more environmentally friendly
uh and this comes down to things that we
do every single day
what could yang possibly be talking
about i'm talking about
bidets have you been to another country
and been like wow what is this device
huh like maybe they figured something
out they have figured something out they
figured out how to
uh to clean our tushies every single
day in a way that's more environmentally
friendly it's more on point
it's uh you know take some getting used
to
but but it's it's a better way to go and
most of us aren't at a point where we're
thinking ooh like i'm gonna install one
in my home
so you know who has you covered tushy
has you covered because it's like an
add-on they stick it on an existing
toilet just any standard toilet and all
of a sudden it's like insta bidet
and it modernizes you it makes you more
environmentally friendly
it'll make you more sophisticated i'll
make you more european actually what am
i talking about i think asia is really
more into these things than anyone else
so if this sounds good to you check out
hello tushy
go to hellotushy.comyang to get 10
off special offer hellotushy.com
yang 10 off hello tishi.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my thrill to welcome to yang
speaks
award-winning musician visual artist
creative extraordinary crimes welcome oh
my gosh guys it's so great to see you
thanks for having me how's it going it's
going
it's going 2020 good is what i say you
know it's like i
i can't complain but the world is
terrible
you know the world is a little bit less
terrible now that joe has
defeated trump and is heading toward the
white house but
that election i know you and i uh texted
about this like
it didn't leave you with a positive
feeling
no it was i mean it was definitely a
high stress situation i think
um yeah um
yeah but i don't know i feel like there
are lessons to be learned from this
well for you you grew up in canada does
american politics
uh horrify you fascinate you like uh
from someone who grew up in our northern
neighbor
which seems like a more rational
place in many ways um yeah like
like how do you experience american
politics that way
well first of all i feel canada isn't
actually as rational
as everyone thinks um you know we are
the home of the crack mayor
rob ford um so oh yeah that guy
yeah um who like got caught smoking
crack and then got caught smoking on
video and then
got caught smoking crack like again and
then possibly the third time so
you know it's like we really we're not
that much better
and actually canadian politics are i
think a bit more crazy than people think
just because we have a kind of like a
three-party system
so a lot of the times the more kind of i
don't know woke vote or whatever
actually gets kind of split between the
liberals and ndp
um so canada actually has its own
problems but
um uh you know which often leads to a
conservative
uh government we we still have like
healthcare
and uh like our college is massively
subsidized which is
like it just actually does make a huge
difference in quality of life
you're you're you're a product of that
right um because canada's
universities including the top public
universities like mcgill
are essentially cost free and i think
like you
attended i wasn't mcgill or like uh like
one of the canada's big schools
yeah no i attended mcgill which is
literally like
a fantastic school like almost for free
like a couple thousand dollars a year or
whatever um and
i'm deeply grateful for that even just
because you can kind of
not know your major going in and stuff
like i feel like in america if you make
the wrong
choice with your major or career like
it's it can be like a
hundreds of thousands of dollars mistake
thousands of dollars in debt yeah it's
true yes so it's like
i mean that's just i i i don't know i
kind of didn't fully comprehend the
situation till i came to america and
met people and it was like damn like i
got to like try out a few different
things before i
you know chose my major so i think this
is
one of the main reasons we think canada
is more rational is that
your education is paid for and you're
not taking 18 19 year olds
and loading them up with debt and then
stressing them out about making
light life decisions where they should
be exploring
yeah i mean i like did not know what i
wanted to do at 18 or 19 like absolutely
not
um you know so uh well actually i did
want to be a musician but
um i didn't think that was a reasonable
career path to pursue
um so it ended up working out but yeah i
know it's like it just seems
crazy that you should be saddled with an
insane amount of debt for decisions
you're making
before you even really know who you are
before your brain is fully wired
seriously
it's highly nonsensical uh and people
are paying for it here
so you knew you wanted to be a musician
did you have a sense of the medium
like did you think i i'm i know it's
going to be
electronic or like you know you'd be the
vocalist or did you dabble with
instruments or what was the story there
um i actually never made music because i
didn't think i
could or should um and then
but i was just like an obsessive music
fan like super super super obsessive
um and then actually in my neuroscience
course or i was in a
uh i was sort of studying music in the
brain
and we actually had a class where we had
to learn logic and like make a song
overnight and bring a song to class the
next day to prove we'd like learned the
um audio recording software
um and that's when i kind of started
making music because i
i like the class provided free audio
software and then i just sort of like
went down the rabbit hole
whoa that is wild uh so
what what year uh in college is that how
old are you
that would have probably been 2009 or
2010 um and then i basically
the first music i made kind of went
viral uh
which was both both a blessing and a
curse because like there's a lot of
footage of me like literally learning
how to make music i've been making music
for less than a year and i'm like on
stage and stuff
there's some yeah um pretty awkward
awkward video of me like being like ah i
accidentally turned
the uh sp 404 off sorry guys and people
but um yeah so
well well certainly at that point your
career starts taking off and you're and
uh you end up making a a career move
which anyone would have been
in your uh position i think the most
fascinating thing about your music is
that
it really feels like you're transported
to another world like i actually
have you actually listened to my music i
have actually listened to your music but
i will confess to you guys
that like if i just listen to your music
um i feel like i'm not getting the right
experience like i feel like i have to be
watching the video in order to
be like i'm not sure how many of your
fans feel the same way but i mean i kind
of feel that way
so i don't know i'm glad you feel that
way i
think yeah yeah because you're such a
visual uh artist and
that there are such striking visuals
again you feel transported to another
world for like a lot of your
um your videos and songs and so i feel
like they all go together in a way that
makes them more complete
like if i'm just listening to the music
in a car or whatnot
like i you know i just feel like
although let me wait until
you know i can be someplace and you know
like watch the video on my phone
i mean i don't know if that that's uh
everyone's attitude but for whatever
reason that's the way
uh i've experienced your music i mean
i'm usually thinking of
um videos like almost all my best songs
i like i was like ooh
imagine if i'm like imagine the scene or
something um
because i direct a lot of the videos
myself or co-direct them with my brother
um and then kind of make the song around
that so um
it is i think core to the music
and speaking of the canadian government
um part of the reason
i was able to even do that in the first
place like being super small and on an
indie label was
the canadian grant system which america
is maybe too big to have
art grants i don't know but that's
another thing that i
super appreciate about being born what
what i mean i didn't know this but what
an incredible story you're like the
product of the public education system
and then you had some kind of
art grants to make some of your first
videos that helped
launch you um so there are programs like
that in the united states but not in the
way you're describing i don't believe
like anyone who's an artist listening
this is like i haven't seen an art grant
in my life in the united states
the people who are saying that are
generally correct
um there there is a national endowment
for the arts but it would not go to an
independent musician that's trying to
make a video
like it it might go to a museum or an
art display
um not there's anything wrong with those
things um but that that's an incredible
story
of the government coming through i know
that that's why
i'm like i mean if you look at the amer
american music in general like so many
of the artists are
canadian or swedish or whatever you know
like
i do think there is you can like see a
direct correlation between the grant
system
and public funding for the arts and you
know um
like i don't know whatever the weekend
bieber
it's drake you know
yeah i i was just at a saturday night
live
um and i was hanging out with jim carrey
and it just struck me that he's another
uh super super canadian who like came
down and took over
you know showbiz so it's true like
canadian influence is very strong
everywhere
one of the things that i found out when
i was running this entrepreneurship
organization
venture for america was that artists
have the same impact on a community's
economic development
as entrepreneurs like if a bunch of
artists move to a community
and then you wait x years that community
will end up
having economic growth
new businesses revitalization in the
same way as if a group of entrepreneurs
went
and this is a major problem for the
united states because in the united
states
uh arts are treated not as an economic
driver but as something of a
luxury or frivolity uh in part because
of what you're describing where you show
up to college and then
anyone who says they're going to study
art or music would be like are you out
of your minds and
uh you know people get funneled towards
quote unquote these more practical
things
um when in truth and you and i talk
about this
like in the future we have to be
investing much more energy in arts and
creativity
uh because ai and technology are going
to do a lot of like the bookkeeping and
accounting and like the practical stuff
that that that people feel like is a
safer career i mean
a lot of this stuff is going to change
pretty quickly
yeah although i do actually think
like at least music is democratizing
really fast um
in part due to the tech companies like
um
you know garageband being free on an
apple computer or whatever
um you know i i actually like i think
you can actually record like
i think like billy eilish said she
recorded her album
in her house or whatever like it is the
technology is kind of getting to a place
where
i think in uh it's just getting a lot
more democratic like you don't
it used to be that you need to be just
really [ __ ] rich or on like a label
that's gonna spend
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars to make an album and
um i think it's interesting because
you're just seeing the amount of artists
making music ballooning
right now um which is cool but then it's
its own
drama because i was actually just
talking to daniel ecke
who runs spotify and they're like you
know there's seven million artists on
spotify or whatever
um and like they feel like they can like
maybe make it so that like a million
artists can make a living off music
um which is still about seven million
yeah yeah seven million
probably it's gonna like double like
it's probably gonna be more than seven
million
um but i don't know like i wonder i mean
i know you're really into like ubi and
stuff like i wonder if there's ways
to like if everything is automated like
if there's
sort of ai and machines kind of like
doing almost
every sort of menial job or whatever
like is there
a world in which if companies aren't
paying employees they can like tax
they can be taxed more like because of
all the extra in theory all the extra
revenue they'd be making it while not
having to pay um
yeah yeah and like you know could that
be
like i don't know i'm actually curious
about like ubi like i haven't read that
much about it like i'm not like like i
don't know what the specifics would be
like how it would be
um accomplished or whatever uh i'm
really
passionate about a lot of elements of
this where
right now so and you know this much
better than i do and you're
like an ultra successful popular artist
but a lot of artists
are dependent upon actually performing
live and touring in order to make money
make a living
you know what i mean yeah um yeah
yeah for you too i mean like you you
understand uh this better than i would
but
uh the digital royalties from like a
spotify
are really really pretty minimal even
for folks who are getting tons and tons
of
downloads and views like i forget what
the math is but it's something like uh
i don't know like a tenth of a penny or
something ridiculous
yeah like maybe you get a few cents
and so there are artists who might get
millions of downloads
uh who are struggling to get by you know
it's
like it's actually yeah it's it's pretty
insane i mean i wouldn't say it's um
just an issue with the streaming
services i think of late
the labels are a huge part of this too
um
i mean in music there's just a lot of
middlemen like you know what once you
have like
you know business management lawyer
manager
booking agent label personally i think
labels pay too much but at the same time
um you know a label is also
can also throw a lot of money down on an
artist and it can fail so it's like
i'm not really sure what the solution is
but i
i do the situation in music worries me
like i know artists that are pretty
successful
that are like broke um and that's not
right
you know like that these are folks who
are uh
millions of plays like they're like
popular artists like
so it's it's yeah um
i feel like we need to sort of like
do something about the middleman
situation but then i like i don't
yeah there is a cost structure where you
have
uh an industry that came of age in a
time when there was a lot more money
flowing through because i'm old enough
to remember going to tower records and
like the cd stories and whatnot
you know that they were like buying this
a lot of times you were buying an album
for like one or two good songs too it
was like you know like that
that was like the way it's um so you do
have some legacy costs
um another big problem though is that
we've conditioned consumers to pay
one uh streaming fee and that's it you
know what i mean it's like if i paid for
spotify then i want all my music for
free um and then
and then the only way you can get more
money out of them is to show up in their
town and perform
which is okay i mean now it's not okay
because no one can perform
um but i think that they're there so one
of the solutions i had
um and you can imagine this as like
universal basic income so universal
basic incomes government
giving everyone money and if we did that
then musicians would make more music and
they wouldn't be starving to death and
people would have more money to
patronize them
and and support them but i think the
move we have to make
is something where we empower consumers
to pay artists directly just by
uh virtue of listening to them or having
their attention like
every american has like a hundred
music books or media books that they
have in any given month
and and by virtue of them listening to
you you actually get
maybe whatever the streaming like you
know pennies are but you get like a
micro fraction of that person's
music box for that month times all of
the folks that listen to it and then all
of a sudden the
money that goes to these seven million
artists in spotify like goes up
significantly
this is like a revved up version of
these public grants you're talking about
where instead of giving
it to the artist we give it to the
consumer so that when the consumer
uh listens to a musician or supports a
musician then the musician gets rewarded
like you would need some kind of
system like that which is actually very
doable like you know it's much more
doable now than it would have been in
another time
yeah or even you know i was listening to
a podcast do you know the revolutions
podcast
mike duncan um i don't listen to it but
i i've heard it
it's an incredible podcast um but you
know it's like he he seems to like
stress it's always just and like harry's
razors and all this and i'm like why
can't there just be a donate a dollar
like why can't i just buy yes
just donate the dollar and like watching
artists scramble for this stuff too and
be like hey support me on patreon
support me on this and
it's like you know it's like if i enjoy
your stuff you should just be getting
value from me
i just feel like every streaming like
every single streaming
service like even like youtube or
whatever spotify there should just be a
little thing at the side of like the
song
cast or the video and it's like i just
want to donate a dollar to this because
another thing i was thinking about a lot
is
music videos for example and i know you
wanted to talk about kpop
which i think is sort of anyway so like
the music video master class
at the moment but um they've taken it to
a whole other level it actually reminds
me of your stuff where it's very
transporting but go on
um but you know it's like so music
videos there isn't a direct
um uh you don't directly profit from a
music video you like pay for a music
video and you just like hope to god
like it makes the song take off or
whatever and that you can like earn the
money back on the video
and like i think this is it's kind of
sad because it's like i think the art of
music videos would be respected more
um if like you could pay for them in an
easier way like when i see a [ __ ]
fantastic music video i'm like damn like
why can't i just give them
two bucks or five bucks like you know um
there are so many problems that are tied
into this but one problem is that our
attention is being monetized in various
ways we're conditioned not to pay
but then we pay this hidden price
because you're selling ads and you're
selling my data and you're doing all
this stuff like particularly social
media world i mean a lot of this music
we're talking about it's on youtube
like freaking you know youtube tries to
monetize us through ads and
they've got very effective algorithms
and rabbit holes uh
and and some of that stuff's not great
you know like there's a joke that
you're always three clicks away from a
conspiracy theory on your
youtube like you'll start watching a
video that you'll wind up
you know watching some crazy video about
pizzerias or whatever
i don't know if this is like a proposed
idea but i've been thinking about this a
lot lately
like you know i feel like under
capitalism like we value things that we
pay for
more than things that we don't pay for
um yeah and
you know like
do you ever get into like that um am i
the [ __ ] page on reddit it's like a
page where people like they
they come and they like say they're like
okay am i the [ __ ] and they like say
their situation
and like there's so many of them with
like you know like a stay-at-home mom
like you know where the husband or
whatever is just like
like you're the stay-at-home mom it's an
easy life like blah blah blah like
everything is paid for um like chill
like you're not allowed to complain and
you know i really started thinking about
the fact that motherhood isn't
compensated
um and it's this weird oh my gosh yes
like motherhood is the hardest thing in
the world
like like like it's so cool
it's way harder than a regular job like
as a person like i thought i was like a
hard ass
like touring and you know just like
like it when you're just like alone with
a baby for
24 hours like you can barely go to the
bathroom like it's crazy like there
aren't other jobs where it's just like
going to the bathroom could just be like
a huge problem and like
you know i'm just holding a baby in your
arms crying and you're like i just need
to pee
like ah you know it's like a really
intensive job and i feel like people
our society super undervalues it and um
you know it's actually one of the most
important jobs like it's like raising
the next generation
what does canada do for new moms because
canada has paid uh
leave and whatnot uh the us is the most
pathologically anti-woman and
anti-family
and when evelyn had our first son
christopher
it was so difficult uh for both of us
but primarily for her
because when you're the dad the baby
doesn't
care about you like the baby's
homed in on mom and food
uh and like the dad like you know i was
um in the way a lot of the time
um but seeing what evelyn went through
and then trying to help
and being you know like uh um
not you know like as much help as i want
it to be um
uh it's so educational like because i
saw what everyone was going through
where like the
the baby um needed her 24 7.
the baby did not sleep more than you
know what i forget what the rhythm was
but
yeah like stop now or then and half the
time even when i was sleeping i was
sleeping on top of her
and so you know she was like kind of
half asleep
[Laughter]
the baby so she was just getting um yeah
it was so punishing
um and imagining a single mom going
through that
uh really broke my heart it's actually
why i ran for president because
i was cocky going into it i was like
there are two of us and where you know
like we have resources in the rest of it
and like it should be fine
and then it was like a bomb went off in
our house uh and
like we both were losing our minds for
months uh
and i just couldn't imagine someone
going through it alone
you know that's the main thing like two
or three days in i suddenly have this
insane empathy and like deep concern for
single mothers like i was just like oh
holy [ __ ]
this would be like like really really
bad if you were
doing this on your own um and like i
think you actually might be
you know people say single mom and this
and that but it like that's like a
really [ __ ] up thing i i think and i
don't think it's a society like we're
considering that
nearly not at all at all because it's
like
yeah the level brutality there is like
crazy
if you yeah going through it alone as a
single mom and right now 40
of american children are born to
unmarried moms uh you know and then some
really
yeah so so some of them like some of
them it looks like they're you know
their two parents in the homes they
happen not to be married but uh in in
many of them
uh it's just a mom like it it's
the new normal really in the u.s
uh and it breaks my heart because like
now i regard every
single mom as a super woman superhuman
uh about 90 of single parents are single
moms too so when you think single parent
you're like there are single dads out
there but they're outnumbered by single
moms like nine to one
yeah well i mean anything but single dad
too i mean if you're you know you're in
the same boat
really so um but i just like i don't
even know how you would have a job and
have a baby if
and like not have another person like i
literally can't like what would you do
like what would you do yeah i totally
agree like it's
unpredictable it's yeah
so we're talking about it now but how is
um like how how is
is it x-812 like how did i pronounce
that
right or i say xai archangel
because but uh there's great dispute um
i think around the world and in my house
because
i don't know his name is malleable um i
don't want to talk about him too much
because i'm like really in the like
wanting to de-celebritize him i i did
i guess i really got in my own world i
didn't think his name would be that big
of a meme
so like when it became like a giant meme
i was like oh
like i already [ __ ] my kid and it's
like no don't worry about it he's got
plenty of time to become
um uh aware trust me you know i've got
two boys and they don't know what the
heck is going on even now and they're
like you know five years older than him
so you're fine don't worry about it i
feel like it's like a consent thing like
a baby can't consent to being like
famous or whatever so i'm like
very cognizant of yeah trying to
keep his life normal and not have him be
like a celebrity baby or whatever
um does he have a does he have the
beginnings of a personality like
is he doing his thing oh yeah yeah yeah
definitely
i mean i think that's what's crazy like
personality seems almost there from day
one
more like day 20 but you know
well one of the things that happens when
you're a parent you'll probably agree
with this
i think uh is that before you you have
children
and you get this like nature versus
nurture debate um
you think like oh it's like they're both
really important it's like 50 50. and
then after you have kids you're like
nature totally
totally like like actually like you know
yeah like he was smiling
and um like reacting to the
helicopters and stuff like weeks before
he was responding to people and i was
like
okay obsessed with aircraft this seems
uh
um so yeah no but it's
i mean because he just his personality
is fully fully like he just
he has his vibe it's just there like i
don't think we could change it like he
enjoys what he enjoys he literally has
taste there's music he hates
like there's music he loves like it's
just like fully set
you know i'm sure i'm sure you could
like i don't know yeah
well i have the same experience where
you know like our boys are
very very specific and has nothing to do
with anything we did
you know like um so parents think it's
more nature than nurture and
apparently science agrees apparently
science says there's a lot of doesn't
mean yeah science does agree it's a bit
more nature than nurture
um so it's not our imagination
[Music]
andrew i want to talk to you about
something called noom
which is basically a psychology focused
way
to lose weight get healthier get your
mind right getting in shape quote
unquote is something that
we all say but it doesn't actually have
to be about losing a specific amount of
weight or a magic number on the scale is
about these healthy habits of feeling
better about yourself which is why the
psychology is really important so
if fitting into your favorite pair of
jeans is great but there are many
reasons you might want to practice
self-care and every person is different
so for me
i find that at least on the trail too
when you're eating like crap or you're
traveling a lot you're working a lot
like the energy starts dropping your
sleep gets a little inconsistent
uh the desire to have an alcoholic
beverage too often
uh creeps up so this app
and website and program noom is pretty
powerful and what you do is you take
this quiz
and we've actually done a fair amount of
these types of quizzes but i really like
this one because it's not just like hey
what's your weight loss number it's like
what's important to you what are you
struggling with what are you uh
passionate about how busy are you what
is bothering you it's just stress level
is it eating it's nutrition it's
digestion whatever it is
um so you create this quiz and it takes
like three minutes or so
if you take it a little more serious put
more thought into probably five to six
minutes
and when you're done you get this plan
and
it's 10 minutes a day of either focusing
on your diet or physical activity or
meditation or whatever you think is or
whatever they determine is
helpful for your efforts
and for your plan and so for me i am on
a
getting shape plan by middle of january
which concludes a little bit of working
out and a little bit about diet
adjustments and i'm just getting started
but i've loved it so far
because it's simple and it's not trying
to hit a home run on your first
at bat like a lot of times when i get
back into working out
i think things like newmar the future
noom represents
the best application of technology to
actually make
us healthier happier sign up for your
trial today at noom
n-o-o-m-dot-com
speaks visit noom.com speaks
to start your trial today
[Music]
[Applause]
so you just had an album come out um the
the creative process
i can't imagine what that's like for you
you know like i have
a couple of things that i work on but
like for you i feel like you have to be
absorbing
uh images and
music and just consuming culture in a
particular way because then at some
point you're going to produce
a video an album and there was a quote
from you that i loved it was something
like i don't want to just be the face of
this thing i produce i want to build it
like it sounds like you really have your
uh your el your elbows deep into
everything that you're doing
um so i feel like to do that you have to
be this kind of sponge where you're
synthesizing
um art and music um
you know maybe not all the time because
everyone needs a break but like i feel
like that must be
uh an important part of your work yeah
no
i think it's yeah i mean i'm just like
constantly obsessively consuming
new music and um you know books or
movies or whatever um it's really
important to me
it's it's actually like one of the
reasons i did the i don't know if you
saw like the i recently released an app
that's like a ai
um yes i wanted to talk about this it
was like um
the digital avatar that people could use
uh
it's it's a different it's like it
creates ai it's like an ai music
generative thing
that makes um audio for babies
um but part of the reason i did it is
like all the baby [ __ ] is so
i um uh i just feel like it's not good
art
like i find it like distressingly
obnoxious um
and like it was stressing me out because
i was like man i can't keep like
engaging with all this bad art
in order to raise my kid because it's
gonna make me a worse artist and also i
feel like it'll make him
[Laughter]
worse taste as well um
but that is so on point because you just
end up exposing yourself and your kid to
this
kind of crap for kids dumb kids stuff is
great
some kid stuff is great like i we were
watching fantasia the other night and i
was like
wow fantasia is a masterpiece like an
otter masterpiece
have you seen that movie that this old
disney movie oh yeah the old disney
mickey mouse the brooms the whole thing
yeah
and did you know what fantasia was made
in 1944 and if you
watch it from the lens of the war it
like completely changes the whole thing
it's like
yeah um great film but um
so i mean there's some i mean some kids
content is in my opinion some of the
best content there's also just a lot of
more like the baby stuff like getting
babies to like
open their eyes and you know you know
like all the little cards where you show
them the black and white thing to try to
get them to learn how to focus like i
feel like that stuff is
just feels weirdly mass produced and not
very artistic
um and i'm like man this stuff could be
it just could it could be prettier and
brought more crimes
if you wanted to uplift that you would
be doing the world
such a massive service uh because
every parent goes through this where you
look up and you're like okay
like how old is my kid what am i
supposed to be doing and then like you
you know like
go online and like buy some products and
you you bring them in
um and a lot of it is not as
uh human as it could be or should be
like that like there there is not a lot
of heart and soul in a lot of it
uh that yeah yeah so if and i know this
in part because evelyn went through some
similar processes
and so what she did is she had like a
scratch pad of
product ideas um and the the funny thing
is that
um by the time you turn to the product
idea as a mom like your kid has aged
into a need for
another product so you forget about that
one
i mean i my brother and i had this
really funny one that like no one would
ever want um
but do you know like brutalist
architecture
yeah yeah like so it was called
brutalist baby
and like everything would just be like
cement like hyper minimalist
um i don't know apparently that for sure
i feel like yeah now they'd be like oh
this is gonna make my kid more rugged
maybe it's like bad for the kid though
to be
maybe it's sort of like pr prison-esque
i don't know but
yeah i'm like super into brutal
brutalist architecture at the moment and
i
thought like brutalist baby like you
know like just like
a square cement crib would be kind of
cool
oh well one of the things you and i you
and i were bonding over which i
i think we need in the world is that we
need more public art like and
one of the fun things about you is like
you're continuously like posting kind of
visions and images
of various uh structures and sculptures
that
that should or could exist in the world
have you been to burning man
i have not i have many friends you've
been i take it you ben
yes and like the thing that
struck me the most about about it is
it's just like art
everywhere and it's just like it just
feels amazing to just be walking through
and there's no there's also no um
obviously sound restrictions so it's
just like every
half a block there's just like a whole
new audio experience and there's just
like
beautiful art everywhere and i'm just
like man
like imagine if our cities had this much
like if you were just to go
make something and just put it there
without all the bureaucracy and
paperwork
and like you know like even i wanted to
like mural my house or like paint it
black or something and like i had to go
through the city council and it was like
a whole thing i was like okay fine i'll
just
have a normal house like you know
because if it's gonna be such a problem
you're gonna devalue the neighborhood
and whatever then fine i i won't like
have a cool house but like
like that's you can't even like mural
your house
we should be able to mural our houses uh
in all seriousness i think public art at
a
bigger scale would be really
transformative because right now one of
the problems with america is that
we're uh cynical about our ability to
change and evolve
uh you know and and that's something
around like a level of
optimism and um
appetite for change in a positive way
and i genuinely think that art can
produce that in people
like if you were walking around a
neighborhood and then that like i guess
in your case like there's like a house
with a giant black mural and you're like
what the heck is that and then it makes
you
like think for a second you just done
like i i was in berlin recently to work
on the app actually and um
like there's just there is there's just
a lot more public art in berlin and i
was just like man this just feels cool
like it just
yes it just makes my day a bit better
like it's just a bit
it's uplifting like you're just more
likely to be positive you're more likely
to be
kind or generous or give someone the
benefit of the doubt when they cut you
off or whatever the heck it is like you
know you're just like
um more more positive to the extent
aside from burning man which
i understand like you know i mean that
that would be uh
like a singular experience are there
american cities that actually are
like not terrible at this where you go
and you're like okay like this place
kind of reminds me of
[Laughter]
berlin in that way or something like
that i'm trying to think
um i mean there's cities like
detroit or baltimore or montreal where
there's just a lot of abandoned
stuff and so there's a lot of like cool
sort of illegal spaces where artists are
residing
um uh like i'm less familiar with this
now but more like when i was in my like
super uh whatever underground touring
days
um and it's not like public but i i it
is
like sick like detroit there are murals
everywhere
because there are like uh there are
buildings that have fallen into
uh blight and disrepair and no one cares
what the heck you do so there are people
going
miami drink our basil which i think they
paint over the murals during the year
i'm not sure
but like it's sick to just like block
some blocks of murals
just it's just i'm like this is nice you
know it's just cool
and then they were kind of having mural
painting parties too where people were
painting murals and there'd just be a
bunch of people sitting around like
drinking and like chilling like well the
artists were painting the murals and i
was like
i don't know it's just nice like if i
had a sunday afternoon off and i was
walking around and i saw someone
painting a mural like i'd probably sit
there and
watch and hang out like nice it's like a
community a community building
vibe exercise yeah in your case you'd
probably sit there and be like you know
what you should probably go in this
direction over there they'd be like oh
yeah you're right
no no i don't want a backseat drive
that's the worst when someone's
like if i'm djing and people come up
with requests i'm like
you know don't want to backstage drive
to other people's art
just enjoy my vision
[Music]
have you wanted to be athletic have you
also wanted to be green
then we've got the product for you
athletic greens
what is athletic greens it's a
nutritional supplement uh what it is
it's a mix you put in with water and all
of a sudden all of these super vitamins
and minerals and probiotics and
everything
that they've scientifically engineered
to be that supplement that you've been
waiting for
that's athletic greens i gotta say you
take it uh it becomes part of a ritual
and then you feel like you did your body
good and your body returns the favor
your body's like ooh
what is this you have given me this is
unusual this is stimulating uh
and then you feel better and then you do
it on the regular and all of a sudden it
feels like you had a much more complete
diet it's kind of a hack
i'm sort of uh i'm sort of someone who
likes to
do things efficiently and athletic green
is a very efficient way
to get the nutrients you need in a way
that you can actually do
so if you're looking to upgrade your
multivitamin to take
one nutritional formula that's going to
help cover you every single day
check out athletic greens it makes
getting high quality nutrition
incredibly easy all in one product go to
athleticgreens.com
yang you'll receive up to a year's
supply of liquid vitamin d for free
with your first purchase ooh free liquid
vitamin d
it's like sunshine in a bottle again
that's athleticgreens.com
[Music]
[Applause]
so i have only recently discovered k-pop
because you know i'm like
like an adult dude or whatever but
um but now that i've discovered it oh my
gosh like i'm convinced that
they've done they've like discovered
parts of our brains
that like activated something really uh
primal and and fundamental in us where
you can just watch that stuff and and
just like like almost fall into
like uh trance like i feel like
i was saying all this the other day i
was talking to my friends the other day
and about i like
my friend like was doing some art and
she was like oh but it's so wholesome
and there's no dark and it was just this
really like
everything was like pink and stuff and i
was like i don't know dude like i feel
like this is like
radically wholesome and it's like being
wholesome is actually sort of
like especially in art it's sort of
looked down upon and like you're
supposed to be a tortured artist or
whatever but it's like it's actually
kind of um
uh edgy to be wholesome at this point
and i sort of feel like with kpop
sometimes it's just it's like radically
wholesome like it's just like
nothing about it is abrasive and like
i think that's actually like kind of a
good thing like i feel like we almost
like don't have enough of that like it's
it's like nice to just like know i'm
gonna like vibe in and engage with
something that's just gonna like
sound great it's gonna look great it's
gonna be positive it's like about
love like there's like dancing like it's
just and it's just
gonna be executed at a flawless level
it's like i feel like it's sort of a
well i was gonna say underrated but
clearly not
anymore um well it's like the artists
are kind of frozen
in time at a particular age and stage
let you know if you had to trace the age
you'd say something like 16 to 26 i mean
i
don't know if that's actually how old
they all are um and
and then the the music's aimed at a
particular demo that's
you know kind of similar but it's also
kind of frozen in time like it reminds
me of
michael jackson and then bruno mars on
top of michael jackson or at least that
bts song that now is on the radio
everywhere
um where um where there
to me and this betrays you know i grew
up in the 80s or whatever but it gives
me like this wholesome 80s vibe
and i happened to have been in my teens
during the 80s so
so it's like it's like transported back
to
um to that point i think elon and i are
like not you know
like around the same age i guess you
might have a year or two on me
um so uh
so i i feel like they've really figured
they've like decoded something
they you know and i mean they've now
formed this billion dollar
creative industry like powerhouse
industry um
uh out of korea um did you see the black
pink documentary that's on netflix it's
like about the kind of training
information oh
there's a black thing talking about
netflix yeah
you really watch that yeah like but so
that they're like it's
it's great and mostly wholesome and the
rest of it but it also
shows the way these girls and they were
girls at the time
i got identified and recruited and
trained at essentially this boot camp
that goes 12 hours
a day like 13 out of 14 days
where they get taught how to sing
dance speak korean uh like generally
traffic in this way and like
and it also talks about how girls get
weeded out
on the regular like they're they're
there and then um you know the person
that they were brought in with
disappears and and like they
they come up and they're training for
this debut
um and their training of this debut like
five years later or whatnot like they
have the this archival footage
of them showing up as uh 16 year olds or
whatever it is and then they're like
debuting at
uh 21. um it's a you're gonna love it
like because you know you're gonna know
okay you know
that is like you know yeah that's the
directly exactly what i'm looking for at
this moment in time
holy cow can they dance like they can
dance like freaking
um they're almost like ai the entire
thing actually k-pop kind of reminds me
of ai
i mean i think they're just they're just
really well trained um you know it's
kind of it's kind of like the
the beyonce thing or whatever they're
just trained from young age so they're
just like actually
super pro like a lot of musicians like
me or a lot of people i know like like
i was 24 when grimes kind of
took off you know and i had put like
very little effort into training as
a artist or you know i'd never even
taken a single look at this crimes one
is daddy's friend
one thing that i know you were inspired
by from one of your early albums which i
was a fan of too was dune
for you was dune the book the early
movie
like wha what was it because you're one
of your early albums you were pretending
to essentially craft a soundtrack for
dune you were like oh if this was
if this was my soundtrack to it well the
tragedy of my life so like my dream as a
child
like i was like i want to be the i want
to direct the dune movie and like even
as a child i always had
i actually like i respect a lot of
things about the david lynch movie but
it's not
this prop maybe this is sort of like
not supposed to say this i don't love
the david lynch movie
um uh i super loved the book like my
i read the book when i was really young
like my dad started reading it to me
when i was like five or six
and then i just like got obsessed with
it and just like finished it like when i
was like
six or something so it's this very
formative experience to me
um uh but
yeah i think dune is like phenomenal
phenomenal i know it's like
i guess sort of problematic in some ways
or
you know um but uh
i'm actually really excited about the
new movie at first i was like
extremely bitter and i was like [ __ ]
danny villeneuve and blah blah blah
blah or whatever but honestly the cast
you probably wrapped around a lot of
these circles have you met um denny
villeneuve or any of these guys
no i've never met him i may be saying
his name wrong but
i recently i just copied my uh
[Laughter]
um but like weirdly timothy chalamet is
actually like a great actor
um and like zendaya like i don't know
honestly the casting in dune is like
almost perfect like it's
probably what i would have done so but
i'm so sad that it's been postponed
it was like i would literally i was like
i was like this is like the light at the
end of the tunnel like of the pandemic
was
going to dune like and i was you know
going to rent out a feeder for all my
friends and
everyone cosplay as a character from
dune
um and i was going to be like a sand
worm or an artistic interpretation of a
sand worm
um but yeah huge tragedy that that film
release has been delayed what um what a
glorious vision
of this uh film premiere or the private
film premiere like i hope this comes to
pass
just delayed you know a bit because like
the
the you and the um sand worm in a
costume would be funny
there'd be a lot of funny things to be
had um
um i'm a dune fan from the book uh the
the movie didn't do much for me
which is kind of funny um but
i loved the world building of the book
and i think that it was almost it was
very very hard to make a good movie
about that book
given filmmaking capabilities
of like the 80s and whatnot yeah yeah
yeah um i mean i
i one of the things that i love about
doing that i think is so interesting is
it's
it's like so far in the future but it's
sort of post technological
you know like ai is banned thinking
machines are banned and so like
people are just crazy mind enhancement
and stuff to like make up for
um you know the technology bands which
is really
really interesting to me um especially
because like i do worry
we might get into a situation where like
governments might start banning
technology um like i think a lot of like
the tech boom has been amazing but also
it
has been quite irresponsible from a
safety perspective and it like
you know i'm worried if the degree to
which like if the irresponsibility
continues we might get into a place
where like
we're shutting down technology like
because we just no no it's a real
i mean right now that's like the
the overreaction that everyone can see
coming uh because right now there
are so many people that do not feel like
they're getting included
by technologies uh forward advancement
uh and that there is something happening
where
uh where technology is consuming more
and more of our time
more and more of our kids time um are
you on tick tock
um on and off i do find the algorithm
to be unsafely addictive so
i'm bingo that's where i was going with
it yeah wait was i talking
about the main technology center for
humane yeah we were talking about
tristana
yeah yeah totally yeah and you know i
think for example like
i was listening to a podcast with
tristan harris and i think it's tristane
whatever i'm saying his name wrong
that's right and um
you know the guy who invented the
endless scroll you know and it's just
like
like a lot of this stuff is like really
addictive and also
like um prioritizes hysteria
and rage um and also just
uh misinformation um and you know i
think it's
like leading to not only like a
political crisis but a mental health
crisis
um yes you know i was also i was reading
this thing about how like you go on
twitter
or whatever and you your brain is kind
of getting the
social chemicals and you're like feel
like you're getting the social time but
you know you're not like there's
different hormonal releases when you're
actually in a room with real people
you know and it's like you're actually
you feel like you're getting social
a social experience but you're really
not and and so it's like people are
kind of having the byproducts of being
quite isolated
um not to mention the lack of sleep like
you know like these things like you're
on your phone late at night like it's
gonna be harder to sleep like i think
sleeping pill usage is going way up yeah
which is leads to less rem sleep blah
blah blah and all this like feeds into
like mental health crisis on top of
you know all the political political
stuff and everything um
but yeah i i it's quite concerning and
you know i was thinking the other day i
was talking some people the other day
um about how it you know it's like we
have global warming and then we have all
these global warming scientists or
whatever
or like we have pandemic and then we
have all these pandemic scientists but
then we have tech
and then there isn't like a tech safety
community that's super large like it's
quite small
it's quite unforgotten the extent that
it exists it's tiny like it's just
the people that he has on the podcast
and that that's like
i think there's like oxford there's like
some stuff at oxford like
there but it's still it's like it's just
not
it you know it's interesting that
when people consider career in tech it's
it's all sort of like making the tech
and none of it is the sort of like the
stuff
about the guard rails yeah yeah and it's
like especially like when we're getting
close to ai
and talking about ai you know it's like
it's going to be super important to have
like
as many people working on ai safety as
the
as much as actually just building
ai this is one of the things i said on
on the trail grimes is that i said look
some of the most powerful technologists
in the world have said to me that they
want guardrails on ai
because all the incentives right now are
to go as fast as possible because we're
competing against each other and the
chinese
and one of us is going to do something
very regrettable
and and so i would say to folks it's
like look if
elon is saying this or sam altman is
saying this then we really need to
listen because these are not people that
frankly generally request guardrails you
know
like that that's not really yeah yeah
yeah yeah no exactly like late
you know they yeah um uh
i mean one of the things that really
concerns me about the state of the
government right now
um you know at the risk of sounding
aegis
is we just have a lot of people in the
government who are like very old they
didn't grow up with the internet they're
not
super tuned into technology like you
know there's people who are like getting
their
they're not even checking their email
like in congress and stuff
they might never check their email in
their entire life yeah like their emails
get printed out and they read the paper
and then like say
you know it's just like this is like
really concerning like i don't think
the government across the board has any
understanding of
technology and that's part of the reason
the facebook situation is so out of
control
we can all see it's happening and you
don't want to be a jerk to be like oh
you know the olds don't get this stuff
but the fact is the average age of a u.s
senator is 62.
so like how many 62 year olds you know
that like understand
like the mechanics of the social media
companies um very few
and there has not been independent
guidance on technology related issues in
the us congress since 1995
you know 25 years so so they're
completely
out to lunch on this set of issues uh
it's corrosive for democracy it's close
environmental health
and i've experienced these social media
apps in a particular way
where i ran for president and tried to
use these apps to the best of my ability
to make my case
and compete and generate a following uh
and so
i've benefited from them tremendously um
yes yep but same i rely on them
completely
to run my business yeah um but i can
very very clearly see the downsides
for users uh where
i think that i'm unusually good on them
and even for me sometimes like i sense
myself
lapsing into like a twitter vortex or
like uh you know like an hour two will
pass
um and yeah and then i'll look up and be
like oh wait like i was supposed to do
this other thing
you know it it feels like you're being
productive in a particular way and
social in a particular way
well you huge reward you know the way
it's been set up like as
tristan harris or whatever says like
it's it's just
rewards we're like ooh like you hit the
heart and go blue like it you know like
the squirrel like this
it's so set up visually to just like
make your brain just like
like tuned in and you know it does it
does feel
semi-productive or you know you're like
oh i'm learning things i'm learning
things but it's like a very shallow
um comprehension you know if you're
getting a one sentence on a thing it's
like ooh like a fact like are you even
gonna remember that and
there's no deep knowledge there um which
and i'm not saying this like
i don't wanna say social media is all
bad social media obviously is great and
you know there's been a lot of like
political organizing and stuff on it so
yeah you know it's it's definitely like
i'm not just saying like
you know [ __ ] social media but but but
there are there are excesses and the
excesses are hitting teenage girls
particularly hard
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean the
beauty stuff i
i think is like concerning
um and i believe that that tick tock is
the most powerful of these in its own
way
like i just got on tick tock maybe um
two weeks ago three weeks ago
and holy cow is that stuff powerful
like you you get in there and uh it's
it's hypnotic uh you know you just end
up seeing these videos of human beings
like like dancing humans are trained to
want to look at human faces
you know it's like like consider the
amount of portraits versus landscapes
you know in the lineage of painting um
like we want to look at humans like
we're you know
i i think yeah i think it behooves most
any adult
who wants to understand what's going on
with the younger generation to try and
spend a few hours on tick tock
just to see what the heck the kids are
doing um
because it's like another language it's
like another visual and digital language
it's got a different energy and
vocabulary different people
uh you know it's like it's fascinating
because like you know i've been on
twitter now for a little bit
and all the media and the journalists
are on twitter and then you go on tick
tock and it's like
just actual like kids having fun
[Laughter]
i think it's great for music for you for
music it would be
i'm sure like a really useful fire hose
you could just like turn it on and like
um get stimulation in a particular way
well it's sort of i think a more natural
i mean maybe there are
you know the dark forces of major labels
pushing certain
songs or whatever but like as far as i'm
aware like i feel like it's just people
like dig a song a song
has a cool vibe with a certain movement
and then like that song can kind of take
off in a
natural organic way and i think that's
pretty cool
um because music is super over gate kept
and i
like i think tick tock doesn't have that
i don't know i might be wrong but
there's a music discovery element and
there are
like undiscovered artists who are just
making their stuff there uh and
yeah yeah and getting found are you
gonna run again
do you think uh i'm almost certainly
gonna run for something at some point
and i i've been
pretty public about that um and i dare
say it would be more fun the second time
than the first time because
we'd start at a higher base
the but the problems are just getting
bigger and hairier and nastier and i
just want to try and solve them for
your son for my sons for everyone's kids
um because you and i are in a position
where we're actually more able to make a
difference in the world and
frankly you know like the vast vast
majority of folks and so
uh like i take that responsibility to
heart so yeah you're going to see andre
yang on some ballot somewhere in some
campaign
i've got a couple of uh visions uh but
first things first
you know we we have um right now this
this might be too um uh too nitty-gritty
for you but we're
heading to georgia for the senate races
uh trying to win the senate
oh yeah for the dems and then
uh you know and then i may end up in the
administration trying to tackle some of
the social media problems you're talking
about
um that would be cool yeah if you if you
if that does end up happening and you
end up like
i don't know like working with the
center for humane tech people or
anything like that like
and you need any help definitely hit me
up
i will hit you up that would be so fun
grimes what we do is we'd have this
um you know this message that we need to
get out um and then you could help
you could like make some freaking
incredible creative for it um we'll hit
you up on that for
for sure look at that you could be like
the champion of the
of the humane technology movement or the
human tech movement
i would love it cool yeah well
anyway i can help just let me know thank
you for listening in i hope you enjoyed
this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you